the world doesn't need another perfect
person the world needs you I doubt you
understand how often your mind is
looking around and talking to you and
spotting things that are negative the
one word to pay attention to his energy
I love that that's it
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you as well
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and learn how to crush
2020 with Mel Robbins
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one stop trying to be perfect I had
something happen yesterday it's
something that I'm not proud of it's
something that I felt really bad when it
happened I had a crazy overwhelming day
everything was coming at me from a
million different directions I was being
pulled in a million different directions
Chris and my daughter was home from
college and she's sorting out her summer
plans and she was getting extremely
stressed out meanwhile I've got a
million emails and so that's how I felt
yesterday and all of a sudden I looked
at my phone and I realized oh my god I
was supposed to pick up our son almost
an hour ago from school my heart sank
I mean who forgets their kid I did I I
just I lost track of time and so I
immediately started texting her son he
wasn't responding I called the school he
calls me I said dude I'm really really
sorry I was doing something with Sawyer
and I'm running really late where are
you bought about 10 minutes wait no
problem on the in the front at school
and he got into the car and I burst into
tears he's like what's wrong and I said
you know I just feel like I failed you
today and I just feel like I am not the
perfect mom that I should be that's the
words that fell out of my mouth and he
looked at me and he goes mom if you had
been on time you would be one of those
perfect moms
are all over there kids that are up in
their business that never do anything
wrong and I don't want a perfect mom I
want my mom oh my god I'm getting really
upset and then of course I started
crying more and I was like that is the
most beautiful thing that you've ever
sent to me because it's true the world
doesn't need another perfect person the
world needs you
and you're trying your best you're doing
what you can and you know I think it's
really important that you cut yourself a
break and that you stop thinking that
you have to be perfect there gonna be
days where you're an hour late to pick
up your kid there are going to be days
when you can't get to every email and
that's okay there are gonna be days
where you feel so underwater and that's
okay you'll get through it you'll figure
it out and you've got to understand that
it's not about being perfect it's about
just being you and that means that you
got to be willing to start before you're
ready you got to be willing to do what I
do every damn day which is show up in my
rollers or start a live stream and
disconnect myself or start it and be
talking and not even know that I'm
broadcasting you've got to do that
version in your life or you're not gonna
get ahead period rule number two be in
control of your mind
so the other day I managed to get to a
yoga class 30 minutes early the reason
why that happened was not because I was
really organized it was because my son
actually had chorus practice at school
so he had to be at school earlier so I
got to the studio earlier and class
normally starts at 8:45 and I normally
get there at 8:40 for 8:45 846 right in
that zone this day a couple days ago I
arrived at like 8:14 and so I go down
the stairs to the yoga studio and I get
up to the door and it's locked
it's dark there's no one there the
reason why nobody was there is they
weren't even open yet that's how early I
was now here's what happened that really
struck me the first thought that popped
in my mind here it was dressed in yoga
gear I got my yoga mat I got my little
journal because I'm gonna be early and I
can journal on my mat be all yogi and
the
to do the first thought that popped into
my mind is oh you should just bail
don't even go go across the street to
Pete's and have a cup of coffee forget
this yoga thing yeah you don't feel like
I cannot believe how fast my own mind
contaminated my thoughts and I doubt you
understand how often your mind is
looking around and talking to you and
spotting things that are negative and
arguing against the things that you know
you want to be doing I mean it was just
a moment walk down the stairs see that
it's dark
I don't think oh great I'm the first one
here that means they'll be the first one
in the door that means I can get the
spot by the door in the back of the
class that I really like I didn't think
oh I could sit here and I could journal
right here and just wait
I didn't think oh I couldn't make a
phone call I thought ah I'll bail on
this commitment I made to myself I'll
just bail out I'll just bet screw it so
why am I telling you this because our
minds are so negative I don't care how
positive you are and I am an incredibly
positive person I don't care how much
mindset work you do you have to continue
to do it over and over and over again
it's not that your mind jumps to the
negative and constantly sees the
problems and the obstacles in front of
you it's that you don't even realize how
often it happens and how often it
hijacks you and takes you off course so
it's essential that you're paying
attention it's essential that when your
mind talks negative smack talked to you
that you smack it back and you say no
thanks or you insert something positive
rule number three go brick by brick in
order to make it stick go brick by brick
in order to make it stick go brick by
brick one of the things that's
interesting about having big dreams and
big goals is that oftentimes the fact
that the goals and the dreams that we
have are so big it makes them really
really difficult to achieve because you
spend so much time thinking about how
big the idea or the dream is that you
become paralyzed in the moment or
taking action how do you build a house
by laying a foundation brick by brick by
brick you go one small brick at a time
and it's exactly the same thing for your
goals by the way so if you think about
where you're at in this moment and you
think about the path that will take you
forward to your big dreams or should
this change that you want to make and
I'm gonna use the eating program as my
example because this is daunting to me I
can come up with a million reasons right
now just like I'm sure you can come up
with a million reasons why you can't run
a marathon you can't do the singing
telegram business you can't take nature
pictures for a living you can't be more
connected to your husband which is what
Lee Ann wants you can't launch that
aromatherapy business I can't possibly
do a structured eating program with the
scale right now because I travel too
much because I'm too busy because I'm
lazy because I'm not deliberate like my
bracelet remember my intent bracelet I'm
reminding myself to be deliberate which
is probably why I'm thinking about this
program the path between where I'm at
and where you want to get to is the same
it is a brick path and it is comprised
of a ton of little bricks that come
together to take me forward and so when
you think about a goal or you think
about a dream as a million little bricks
that come together and lay a path
forward that's the way visually you can
break down your goals and so for me you
know what that one brick could be today
it could be asking Chris or my
brother-in-law for the phone number of
the person not even making the call
people I'm talking about breaking it
down to one brick so I will get that
phone number and I will write it down in
my little red book or I will write it
down and my five second journal and that
way I will have the number and guess
what the brick is going to be tomorrow
the brick tomorrow is gonna be to call
the guy right and make an appointment
and then the next brick might be to read
a little bit and so the key is going
brick by brick to make it stick because
if you think you can lay the whole path
between where you're at and where you
want to go right now you're nuts
also if you want to have more confidence
and self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join our new
description below everybody gives too
much of a [ __ ] about what everybody else
thinks and you know who they think them
out there they're worried the most about
the print I know that everybody's
problem comes down to one pattern you're
repeating that you can't see in order to
get to the next level in your business
you got to decide right now what habits
do you have as a leader that you have to
change now rule number four chase energy
I think you should chase what energizes
you everyone talks about passion legacy
purpose yeah the one word to pay
attention to his energy I love that
that's it but simplify this okay so
whatever energizes you naturally expands
you feels like possibility is exciting
to do and maybe scary that doesn't
matter it has to do with how it makes
you feel right when you were in your 20s
money made you feel good it expanded you
it energized you chasing the money that
was the game that was your passion that
was your perfect there's nothing wrong
with that nothing wrong with that and I
particularly want to say that to the
women that are larger because it is
socialized into women not to chase
success like that not to go after the
money and so if what energizes you is
amassing wealth go for it but what
happened and and the reason why I say
that is because people talk about the
word passion yeah or purpose right and
the truth is it's not a person place or
a thing
it's not it is the feeling of being
expanded and energized great if you're
pursuing your passion it means that you
wake up every day and are energized so
instead of trying to think what's my
purpose what's my passion was my purpose
what's my passion
Canoga yeah instead of thinking like
that I want you instead to ask yourself
what's what could I do today that would
energize me what energizes me if it's
making money
figure out how to make money if it is
making a difference figure out how to
make a difference it could be in any
single shape or form but if it energizes
you that's what you need to follow and
what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time because when you first start making
money it's thrilling yeah thrilling
there is nothing more exhilarating than
making your first million yeah nothing
more exhilarating but what happens is
once you learn how to do something once
you can do it over and over again and so
it starts to become routine yeah which
means it's no longer energizing right
which is why every entrepreneur out
there goes through the mode of chasing
the money and then you hit the money
that you need to make then you're like
I'm not fulfilled yeah do that finally
you know I did that yes yeah and it's
because you were energized by the money
and now you're not yeah now you got to
be energized by the next thing we number
five stop complaining
Debra says what about complaining about
things that genuinely take time to
resolve like I'm getting over being sick
let me ask you a question does
complaining about being sick actually
help you get better it's a fair question
you're allowed to complain if it's
productive if it makes you feel better
to go and saying it is helpful terrific
if doing that makes you feel even worse
try not to do it say things like boy I'm
on day three of this I must be getting
better boy
the meds are gonna kick in at any moment
you know when it starts chris is looking
at me like what are you talking about I
was just somebody mentioned do thoughts
count yes outbound sort of out outward
complain
yes complaining in your own mind of
course thoughts count because you know
what you complain about the most
yourself your body your intelligence
what you just said the fact that you
didn't go to the gym the fact that you
didn't do what you said you were gonna
do the beating yourself up as a form of
complaining because you're expressing
dissatisfaction for yourself and the
problem with all this is that when you
do it habitually or when you complain as
just a default mode and you don't
realize how much you're doing it you're
allowing your mind to filter the world a
certain way and you're allowing yourself
to live in existence where your own
thoughts are poisonous if you feel like
hell and you got the flu and you've just
thrown up in the toilet complain all you
want vent all you want you just earned
that but at some point you're gonna have
to stop feeding the monster and putting
poison in your own mind and you're gonna
have to teach yourself how to start to
find milestones that are positive so
that you can become healthier so that
you can change how you think rule number
six don't make busyness a habit let me
talk to you about Dan so Dan was the
first person and take control that I
coached and he is a super successful guy
he loves what he's doing right now he is
I think the world's best phys ed teacher
he's a total pro at it he loves his
students he's been doing it a long time
but he is starting to panic about the
next chapter of his life he's starting
to panic about the fact that you know
time is ticking and I love what I do but
I'm not sure this is my true calling how
do I figure it out how do I make sure
that I don't wake up at the age of 70 or
80 or 90 and realize that I never
actually went for the thing that I
really loved and a lot of times going
for the thing that you really love
doesn't mean quitting your job
it means figuring out
how to be more focused and deliberate in
your life so that you can start to add
in incremental progress every day on
inching forward that side hustle that
passion project that book you've always
wanted to write and so one of the first
takeaways from Dan's coaching session
one of the first takeaways is busyness
and we take a look at the fact that yeah
there are a lot of you that are really
busy because you got a lot going on and
then there is the type of busyness that
we keep in our lives because by being
busy you convince yourself that you're
in control by being busy you fill up
your life so much that you also also
have an excuse for never ever ever
having the time to do the thing that
scares you which is to write the book
start that passion project work on your
side hustle and so you got to be very
careful if you're somebody who feels
like you're busy all the time to
understand that busyness can become a
habit and busyness can become your
biggest excuse and rule number seven the
last one before very special bonus clip
is hone your skills I want to talk to
those of you that are working toward
your dreams whatever it is that you're
doing right now it's leading to the
thing that you dream of doing and you're
not going to progress until you get the
skills and the experience that you need
at the level that you're at I guarantee
you even if you're working at a front
desk job at a local gym you're learning
customer service you need to learn that
kind of stuff before you can launch your
own business for me in order to be an
incredible speaker that can command the
stage with 3,000 people in the audience
for an entire hour I first had to learn
how to have the courage to speak up and
have hard conversations in my life then
I had to learn how to speak up in a
small meeting then I had to learn how to
speak up you know in a church basement
then I had to learn how to give a little
bit of a talk at a brown-bag luncheon
then I had to learn how to
and on a slightly bigger stage so if
you're frustrated with where you are
right now because you've got these big
dreams and you think you're really far
away here's one way that you can
continue to be patient and you can milk
wherever you're at to help you build the
skills and the experience that you need
as you climb toward the thing that you
want ask yourself what is it that I am
learning what's the skill that I'm
honing by sitting here at this front
desk job or driving this uber or lyft
vehicle what am i learning that I'm
gonna take with me on my journey to do
that next big thing because I guarantee
you there's something in the minutiae of
what you're doing right now that you are
developing an expertise and a skill
around that you're gonna need as you
launch yourself towards the next thing
now I have a special bonus clip with Mal
on how to be with the right group of
people that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question of one what
is the most important skill that you
need to hone number two where do you
need to stop making busyness your habit
and number three where do you need to
stop complaining and if you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well when I'm with cooler or
popular guys I feel inferior and
worthless which affects me and weirdly I
try so hard to impress them and be like
them like a chameleon I try to avoid
them that I feel left out whatever I do
I feel sad or useless what can I do in
order to overcome this you don't have to
hang out with people you don't like
there's a pro life tip for everybody you
don't have to one of the things that is
a massive indication that you're hanging
out with the wrong group of people is
that you don't feel comfortable being
yourself
the second you try to be somebody else
or you feel like a chameleon just to fit
in you are trying to fit in with the
wrong group relationships only work when
you can be the real you people thrive on
energy that's what drives connection
you're with people that make you wither
and hide and feel insecure you are with
the wrong people if it's hard to be
around people you're with the wrong
group of people when relations
chips work they work because they click
and the reason why they click is because
you can be the real you they don't make
you feel inferior you're making yourself
feel inferior by hanging out with people
and pretending you're not yourself so
every time you're hanging out with a
group of people and you act like a
chameleon you're actually invalidating
yourself because your own actions are
telling you you're not good enough to
just be yourself around these people so
the only way to deal with this is either
show up with that group of people and be
your full self and every time you think
something inferior just knock that
thought out of your mind say what you
really believe be interested in what
you're really interested in or the
easier route honestly dropped the
popular kids and find your people you
need to find your people and your people
are the kind of people that the second
you hang out with them you don't feel
like less of yourself you feel like more
of yourself you don't feel like you got
to hide or be somebody else you feel
like you want to express yourself and
show up and be more of yourself that's
the indication that you have found your
people
if you want to know the secret to
immortality check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I believe the only reason we age you
know we could live for a thousand years
otherwise the only reason we age is that
our repair systems become complacent